[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette sculpture qui est donc est
derrière moi puisque nous venons de
l'installer est une réponse cultural à
une demande que m'avait faite
l'établissement public d'aménagement du
plateau de saclay pour accompagner sur
le plan artistique
l'ensemble des écoles d'ingénieurs
plutôt scientifique et même toute
scientifique qui s'installe petit à
petit sur ce plateau c'est incroyable
plateau que ce soit super legs bien sûr
centrale nst qui est juste derrière nous
et d'autres
il m'a été demandé de travailler sur un
thème de la science et j'ai donc
souhaité travailler sur le thème qui est
derrière moi qui ai l'adn qui pour moi
est la molécule la grande molécule phare
de la biologie donc de la science du
vivant
cette molécule semble jaillir de la du
globe terrestre qui est juste en dessous
est en fait la métaphore est la suivante
c'est que la composition chimique de la
terre a bien évidemment déterminée de la
composition chimique de la grande
molécules du vivant qu'est l'adn que
l'on retrouve dans tout le vivant
d'où le thème de la sculpture qui
s'appelle adn unités du vivant puisque
cet adn on va le retrouver dans tout ce
qui est vivant
alors il s'agit d'une sculpture qui est
une pièce unique que j'ai fait pour
cette installation ici elle errait en
bronze
elle a été coulé par une fonderie dans
l'est de la france va fonder deux
royaumes et elle est donc de quatre
mètres de haut
en plus de son socle en béton un socle
en béton que j'ai souhaité
voir ressembler à celui de hoeness qui
juste à côté pour créer une sorte
d'unité visuel dernier petit clin d'oeil
peut-être à cette sculpture tout en haut
il y a comme une sorte quand on regarde
de côté il ya une sorte de sphère en
vide qui rappelle ou qui évoque la lune
pour pouvoir observer la lune il faut
l'adn du cerveau des humains qui permet
de comprendre ce que sont les astres
voilà donc il ya tout un tas de symboles
qui viennent se greffer les uns sur les
autres ou s'enrichir les uns sur les
autres
voilà ce que j'ai souhaité faire et je
suis très reconnaissant à le pea et à la
ville de gif bien sûr de ma va confier
un tel projet
[Musique]